the jurogan experience yeah i think
one big point about what you're saying
about these influential people too
is they they benefit from strife
they benefit from conflict and so
instead of uniters like martin luther
king jr you have the opposite
you have people that literally benefit
from people being divided
they benefit from calling people out or
yelling people down or you know getting
getting conflict going like that that
gets them more views i mean that's
what's going on with facebook
that's what the algorithms that people
are complaining about that are
literally accelerating our path towards
some sort of civil war
yeah do you see the social dilemma i did
see the social dilemma scary [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] and i tell you what i was watching
actually on the plane was this uh do you
remember the duke lacrosse players
yes you remember that story yes dude the
duke lacrosse players so
the whole media uh had kind of indicted
these guys
and they loaded this story with you know
class and race
explain the story it was a bunch of
lacrosse players they had a party right
a bunch of guys had a party at their
house yeah they're uppity white guys
they play lacrosse
so it's like nobody comes from the
ghetto and plays lacrosse
so you know that they're arrogant white
guys who probably
you know their father may have like a
third they definitely have a portrait in
the foyer
of like this is my uncle his ties go
back to england or whatever right so
they're douches we get it
but um they had a party and somebody uh
hired some strippers and the strippers
that came were like two
um pocs they were post you know poc
and uh one of them a lot of people
listening like pocs are people who um
historically disenfranchised little
darker melanin
tones people of color people of color
people of color
um and so they came they stripped but
the girl they only shipped for like five
minutes and the girl was saying weird
stuff and
um then they got mad the guys got mad
because they felt like they were getting
uh conned that they didn't get their
their lap dance worth or whatever their
dancing worth and then something went
awry
and then the girl called the cops and
said i was assaulted
and then from there it became a big
story and it ended up
that the prosecutor was without
withholding
exculpatory evidence that would have
exonerated knowingly i mean he ended up
getting disbarred and
doing time because of this and uh and
you look back now you're going like that
guy was doing exactly what online
personalities do now yeah it's like this
is good for me
right i'm in the spotlight i'm this hero
convicting these douchebags
there's the media's attaching this big
social justice cause to it
there's there's this evidence that
clearly my client is lying
let's just put it to the side because
all the attention's on me and
this is self-aggrandizing for me so i'm
benefit forming i'll just lie
and just you know there's some evidence
that comes that uh you know contradicts
what i'm saying let's just
because right now i'm a star and uh so
these kids were maligned by the media
all these
uh journalists writing this horrible
stuff about these kids the culture
of the lacrosse players the the
privilege the white
privilege this that they did this to
this poor black person you know and
then it was loaded because of durham
because you got duke
and duke is like the harvard of the
south and then you got poor doram
and then it was all [ __ ] it was all
[ __ ] the dna exonerated
the three kids that were on trial and um
it ended up just this girl was like had
some mental health problems she ended up
like killing her boyfriend or something
and is in prison like a couple years
later she was like off you know
and um so a few journalists apologized
but by that time it was like you know
now
you go to comedy clubs the joke that
comics tell the most
if they see a like five like waspy
looking white guys they're like yeah you
guys look like
the duke lacrosse play like that you use
it as a pejorative so it doesn't matter
if it's true
because the media made it true so a lot
of people don't even know
that they did nothing because the
narrative had already been written
right that's the problem that's the
problem the problem is once the
narrative gets out there any
any if there's some sort of a correction
in the newspaper a couple weeks later
it's always on like the fourth page
in the lower right hand corner sorry we
have the amendment to the story
yeah turns out nobody raped anybody
whoops yeah sorry sorry we ruined your
life forever but we sold a lot of papers
with that
so that that isn't a real issue
here's a real question should you be
able to
make money off the news it's a good
question
it's a good question because if you can
make money off the news
then all of a sudden the news becomes a
show and the more outrageous you can get
it the more clickbaity you can get it
the more you can sort of jazz up the
headlines and distort the story
the more you're going to get people to
tune in if it bleeds it leads yeah let's
go
i remember when i was working for fusion
which was like a short-lived uh
company under that was owned by disney
and um univision it lasted like a year
it was totally like
they tried to build a big studio in
miami and they were trying to target
millennials but by that time like
everything was on the phone people were
watching you and it was like this is
just a waste of money
but i remember one of their slogans was
like start a fight
and i was like yeah because my co-two my
two co-hosts were journalists and it was
run by journalists and i was like the
comedic guy that you know they
oh they had me in a corner and they
opened it up and i came in i was like
to make people laugh but but i was
working with like a peabody
award-winning journalist uh you know
mario
mariana atencio and pedro andrade
andrade he's uh they
he was um from brazil and they were two
serious journalists
and uh you know the the when they
the executive producers sat it down was
like pick a fight always look to pick a
fight and i'm like wow that sucks
that sucks yeah that should be happening
in mma with the matchmakers not your
news
that's hard to hear yeah pick a fight
pick a fight
because it gets ratings people love the
drama they love it
i mean if you turned on a real reality
tv show
it would just be like a couple of guys
sitting around you know
yeah picking their nose changing
channels but then if you make a reality
you're like they tell you they have
that's
not that's not reality the blind
producer is going okay call him the
n-word now
he's like i don't want to call him the
n-word like no trust me we'll figure out
you know it'll
and then we'll bleep it out no one will
know what you said yeah then they let
you
they then they start with the end and
lead with the r and you're like hey
i bet you puck was a really good guy i
bet you they just edited it
you remember puck from real world he was
sticking his finger that's right he was
million pedro
he was a mess but the problem with those
guys is that
you make him more of a mess by shining
the camera on him and then you make him
famous didn't he like lose his marbles
after he got off that show
because he was like one of the most
famous guys from the real world other
than theo vaughn
yeah catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience